为读书的人其实是不读书的
我们很认读书的方法是错的
你有没有能感觉
就是我读了好多书
其实我也特别努力
但是我根本就记不住
更不要说用出来了
为什么呀
因为你读书的方法是错的吗
很多老会都知道我读书的书读
非常快
处理直的书读非常快而且马上能用出来
而且最近感觉我的书都更快了对吧
今天和大家分享一下我的方法
就是急速越独发
学义办法
其实就两步
第一步的话就是拍摄
我刚才说
真正会读书但是不读书的
它是靠什么呢?靠一样的
为什么
前面拍摄是什么意思
就是用图形的方法
比如说你像我在
越独之前
我越独的时候我基本上都会画出来
现在有更好的方法
这是为什么我的速度快得原因
为什么
我大家解释科学语句是
我们大脑处理途相的速度是处理文字的
6万倍
因为我们的
有30%是市局批创
大脑捡
这是我科学语句的
所以你会发现出于
市局的速度会快很多
我们一般来很多人读书是怎么读的呢?
一上来就是看文字
抽下的文字然后就理解
理解完击
但是图像的速度会很快
我个人的话就原意画图
只是我以前的方法
但是我为什么说现在速度更快呢?
因为AI可以帮你快速地持续固架
会是生图形
所以那个图像你上来就是立体的
你上来就是图架
我们的值得
12345核心电视什么?
我们现在讲什么?我们的什么
就是图架
而不是一上来就是个陷阱的
然后我现在读到哪了不知道然后再去穿联然后再去理解
所以第一步是
拍摄就是
我说的拍摄就是
用图形的方法去理解整个的固架
但是现在AI的话可以帮出我们更快的就完成这一步
但是这个东西只有固架
是没有雪楼的
第2个来吧
第2个其实就是
拍摄
导演
就你可以把它的意见就是研系
怎么
怎么说一个事里面就理解了
比如说
你们可能看书看蓝茶一段时间
书里的一些细节你几不住了
但是你就看这个
你过了好多年有些情言你记忆这么人生活
对不对
所以一个比较好的方法是什么呢就是
你要把自己放到场景里就像拍电影量把这个过程中拍出来
在几个小例子你们就知道了就我们很就拍完这边
就像说
搞错我写好了但是我几不住搞在呀还在背地说很
很生命
我告诉你你们背就错了因为以前当云相当把那个文字走上理解再走上圖像
但更好的方法是什么是持续就是把它拍摄出来
我举个例子啊我我你们现在拍完这边可能也就是个五分钟到十分钟
啊也就在这样子吧
你就知道吧我以前演讲
一言讲就一言讲三个小时
我演讲的啥小时
从来不用搞子
而且效果非常好你们知道为什么
都会我拍到这边都不用搞子
对我告诉你怎么做
就是去演讲之前
战略那个台下
开始做梦了
哇我这个时候做上台
然后我也开始
然后这个时候我们是怎么互动的
然后我开始讲第一点
第二点这三点
所以个学习历史最好的方法是吗
就是你直接进到那个场面里面
然后我现在在那高的成长上原云开始进攻我们
千亿云万马到画面
然后旁边的死亡上然后你感觉你居身人质对吧这个时候其实你掉了
你的视觉你的听觉然后你的立体感觉就很多高手都采用这个方法
对吧比如说哎呦他16次的时候
就是总是想自己做的光作诱事情对吧
顶尖的医生再做手术之间
都是在打倒里面去过一边的
所以各位
其实你会发现
正确的学义方法不是去理解文字
然后再去理解了
然后再去记忆的不是的
而是一上来用涂行的方式
现在哎哀可以帮我们快速的新生物价
这就是一个国家的有个方家了
然后用监戏的方式然后进去
感受
失去我们的听运立体感觉
而且在这个光中你要天中很多那种的比如说谁
有多少人在什么地方做的什么事
为什么去做这件事他们是怎么做的
整个都是
都是立体的
所以各位
真正会多说的人是不多说的
他不是输入
而是
製造
体验